The joe rogan experience.
I know my memory is unreliable.
That's what the point I'm at.
That's hilarious.
I can mind everybody's memories.
Unreliable people,
they morph their memories to make them more convenient for their knowledge of
the past,
whether it's as them as a victim or as them as the winner or as them as the,
you know,
oh I didn't get my fair shake.
You know,
there was some behind the scenes shenanigans.
Meanwhile it's,
you are a fucking idiot.
Reliable,
but they're going to use this machine.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're not ready yet.
But one day they will,
one day we'll be able to access each other's brains.
Just like you,
we send each other photos.
Like if you were somewhere cool and you sent me a photo and get it on my phone,
we're getting you going to be able to see my,
my,
I'm going to be able to,
you know,
put public.
So,
ah,
I want make my uh,
my eyesight public cause I'm at Yellowstone,
you know,
and you'd go public with your vision and you show everybody else and he can put
it up on a database where people draw from.
That'd be like the first step.
People will share their experiences.
A few people sneak in porn or them jerking off before I park people.
People get to share experiences and then it'll just go to a,
Hey I'm Carl,
I'm always on the,
this is the baddest motherfuckers always on 24,
seven you can watch them shit.
You can watch him jerk off,
you can watch them at Sachs and people just start,
they only live their life.
Can't wait to get home with be Carl is it can't wait to cross out there just
doing ecstasy and bag and bitches driving the fast lane.
The animal.
If Carl's channel became public,
everybody would want to just be inside.
Cross.
Yeah.
You can be the hottest selling.
And people would start complaining.
They would say,
look man,
nobody is living in a real life anymore.
Everybody's living other people's lives.
Came up with a great concept movie.
You doing it right?
Yeah,
because your life is boring as fuck,
but you could just be a Carl.
Carl is out there,
Baldwin and it.
Paul gets Carl gets shot.
Boom.
You're used to go back to regular life.
That's the risk because then you'd have to find a new channel to subscribe to.
You know Carl's dead.
You're just going to follow Eddie for TV shows.
Exactly.
I follow Eddie calls best friend.
That will be a new art form.
The new art form would be living your life in a spectacular manner to which some
people would want to actually give up being a real person so they could be you
and experience it directly and you will become a million people.
They see through you.
We not exactly sure whether or not they influence Carl.
We think that Carl is acting independently,
but it is possible if you think about it,
that all those minds linked up together could form one unique and universal
direction in which crawl might want to go.
Well,
that's kind of like Instagram right now.
That's bananas,
but you're talking about,
I'm taking it to the next level sign
because if call realizes he gets a lot of views what he's doing,
then he's going to do more threesomes course and if he gets a lot of views when
he realizes that he's on a plane or in a Jacuzzi,
he's got a doer that look,
when a guy gets recognized for being a big fat guy and like gets famous for
being a fat guy.
If you ever seen one of those guys,
talked to their agents and the agents will tell you,
I've seen in half with my own eyes,
don't lose weight,
man.
If you lose weight,
you're gonna lose roles.
Right?
Why is that?
Because,
because they've locked onto the idea of you as the fat guy.
Right?
They just decide.
They decide.
We still,
let's just gonna we'll just keep this going.
Don't fuck this up.
You willing to literally retrain.
People know they just keep eating so they'll stay fat and funny.
If you told the fat guy like,
hey dude,
people love eating and if you just,
I just need you to just go fucking crazy.
If you just eat a lot,
bro,
all day,
people are going to just be you as a lot of fat people.
There's skinny in real life,
right?
But they could live like a frat guy through you and we can make money.
I'm Skechers is it on this?
He wants to sponsor.
So you're eating show.
Let me get some guy who just all day he does.
He drinks fucking vodka and he eats subs.
Just ball subs.
Chicken parm all day so people subscribe just so they can experience what it's
like to be fucked up drunk with a chicken like a chicken Parmesan.
Sabalos grapeseed meatballs and sausage and pepper shit and not allowed to eat
anymore.
Live follicles.
Drunk life.
Follow that.
And every now and then Carl,
go to a massage parlor and get jerked off and like,
yeah,
it'd be,
can't tell your wife about that.
Like Carl's doing some crazy shit.
What's he doing here?
Like three sandwiches.
Yeah,
you,
you beat car all.
You don't even tell everybody about Carl getting jerked off.
He's eating a sub while he's getting charged off.
The kid's a maniac.
That's,
I like this.
That's the next level.
Shit,
man.
That's what's going to happen.
People are saying the kids are wasting their lives.
Right?
You're just wasting live sitting there watching TV.
You're not even been out there doing anything.
Well,
that's just TV.
TV,
TV is like the smoke signals of entertainment.
I mean,
it's beautiful for us,
but so was a smoke signal when you didn't know where the fuck the camp was.
Where is everybody?
Right?
They used to all those.
You're a fucker.
I can find them.
That is a lifesaver,
especially when it's cold out.
That shit was a lifesaver.
Right?
That's the TV is,
is the smoke signals of digital entertainment.
One day you're going to actually be that.
You're going to be in that guy's head.
So are you starting already slowly with reality shows and all that stuff,
but we're all going to be one.
Everybody got Facebook,
everybody got to Instagram.
Everybody's on something.
Shit's weird.
You can,
you can you,
you know,
you just can't stream it the way you're talking about what you know that's
coming,
that's going to happen.
It's going to be weird as fuck.
Yeah.